every moment
is filled with worry for emma mother to
a teenager
who's among thousands of children
waiting for specialist treatment for an
eating disorder emma's daughter who we
won't name in order to protect her
identity
is in a children's hospital but she's
not getting the complete care she needs
at the moment she's not with people that
are trained
to deal with mental health and she's
stuck in a room all the time she's not
getting to engage in activities with
other children she doesn't really do
much she's not allowed out of the
building
i just think she's getting worse in
there
nhs data on eating disorders shows a
four-fold increase in the number
of children and young people waiting for
urgent care
if you're not getting that special input
on people who understand how the eating
disorder can
really start to affect someone's mental
health then
generally it's likely that it could
deteriorate they're not getting the
right treatment so they're not getting
the people that can support them to
really start to fight that voice in
someone's head
nhs england says it's investing in
mental health through things like
increased funding and the introduction
of helplines
a spokesperson told us thanks to the nhs
long-term plan
an additional 345 000 children and young
people
each year will get help with their
mental health and well-being
and 40 million pounds has also been
invested in additional inpatient beds
so if you are struggling or have a child
who needs help
please continue to come forward to get
the care you or they
need so that's her in the hospital
emma says this hasn't worked now in her
fourth month of waiting
her daughter she says makes two attempts
every day
to run away from hospital last week she
was found
three miles away she just wanted to get
away
she got really scared she was sat in a
field for like an hour
and um this was after she were crying
and hugging me and she was saying mom i
were really scared i never thought i'd
see you ever again
i was sat in this field and it was pitch
black the hospital told us its clinical
teams are trying to provide the best
care possible
and that it's working with the nhs to
help secure a suitable place for emma's
daughter's care
but she says the longer her child has to
wait
the more her condition worsens sadia
chowdhury sky news
in sheffield